I'm here with Peter Heine Nielsen one of
the driving forces behind magnus carlsen
success in recent years Peter welcome to
st. Louis welcome to the show last a
little bit about your involvement and
how it started with the world champion
well he wasn't exactly the world
chairman at the time I mean I think
maybe like a bit more than 15 years ago
well he was a small kid but he's from
Norway I'm from Denmark so we would I
mean we're very close country so I they
would tell me there is this sort of
talented kid and there was some training
camp in Norway where has something to do
with the older kids and then I did a
small lecture for the world you know
they absolutely - and Magnus was there
and we spoke a bit and I think he
invited me to come a couple of days for
training and we basically got very
friendly and well quite soon also he
became this strange situation that well
he was like 14 but he was the second
highest rated player in Scandinavia
after me so well I think at 14 I started
to see him as a colleague although that
he was still a kid
so basically well we have some I wasn't
training he was just come to visit me in
Denmark for a couple of weeks and know
well we looked at chess and we played
football of whatever and became a sort
of a mixture of friends and colleagues
but of course also but the age
difference some kind of trainer yeah
play a relationship in some sense and
then weld to make a sort of huge leap
forward in 2013 he asked me to be his
head coach and I said sure I've been
there in essence tell us a bit about
your relationships during camps because
you stay with him for like months at a
time how does a usual day in in one of
the World Championship camps cope Magnus
is not known as a sort of well you say
extremely dedicated trainer in that
sense so that's more I mean I used to
work for Anand and I think in 2012 we
had a camp that started mid-january and
it ended the mid-april so that was quite
awful on Magnus camps are a bit shorter
in some sense but of course it's a huge
mixture of locating at openings playing
training games but opens to say well you
know he faces Khurana next months
hopefully he's prepared some surprises
but he needs to practice them in some
games so we invite some friends so but
also it will be quite sociable so we
would look at some sports and we will do
some supposed to be in physical shape
and such so it's
I mean it's probably not like a regular
sports camp but even I think last time
you went to listen to sport which is
sort of a sports kind of con well sports
sports place in the Canary Islands and
well we could do all kind of different
sports so we playing football playing
basketball and there was a lot of people
was trying for three at Lund and we will
go and train just as well so I mean well
Magnus is Magnus and he does his way and
with Vichy we were doing things
differently but I think the point is but
these players were geniuses they do it
their ways and it work and it's not
really my job to tell Magnus maybe we
should do different it because well I
think it's pretty obviously he's doing
quite well absolutely every player is
different and he's a very interested in
sports you also are very interested in
sports and he made a comment yesterday
that you became interested in baseball a
few years back tell us how that started
and why did you watch the Cardinals and
the Yankees well that's quite weird but
there was this excellent movie called
Moneyball and know it got me completely
hooked on on baseball so I started well
it's sort of about a the Oakland A's was
a very poor team and they'd have to beat
the the stronger seems like the Yankees
the rich it once they have to think very
interesting statistically and spend
their money wisely and so I got very
much into that it's something called
sabermetrics it's about well baseball
statistics on how to you know maximize
your chances I think even I took an
online class at Boston University to
sort of get into that so well I got
fascinated by baseball also but when you
work at such as the second right you
know it will be many nights where you
have to study and the good point is that
baseball is every night for tons of
hours so I can watch cause baseball
games when I do that so it's fitted
quite well but well you asked about
sports in general also and I think
Magnus is a huge basket and football fan
so well we spend a lot of time together
we have to talk about something style
it's almost part of my job to also be
updated in sports in basketball front
did you manage to apply this data
statistics to chess
actually it's strange but I mean we
think chess is a strategical game is a
strategical game on the board but it's
not like you know baseball that the
score is five three and such you have to
do certain things I mean in chess well
do your opening preparation and try to
win the game that's more or less it
baseball and let's say football
basketball as
kind of much more sort of complex
strategies and deaths and so a strange
list I think in chess there is little
strategy off the board it's actually
very very straightforward well little
baseball and basketball you have to
swing in a completely different way so
it's kind of weird and the final
question what is the number the
percentage number that you would give
Magnus as a chance to win this event
that's a good question no 53 something
like that I don't know well I still I
think five rounds left and such and
hopefully I mean that's not jinx it but
if he gets to a playoff he normally does
well and such he still has good chances
of course well I mean sometimes he often
gets in his sprint and in sacrum it got
a bit earlier so there is still time for
Sprint so I'm still optimistic but well
if he doesn't win this one it's been a
good year anyway so I'm not too worried
awesome thank you very much for stopping
by
you okay guys